- Welcome to the show.
- [Markella] Thank you.
- I literally feel like I know y'all
but it's weird cause you're not
in costume for me right now.
But, I love the show.
I know. Well, wait, here you go.
I love the show.
I'm gonna just tell you in the beginning,
I never saw the movies
and I don't know why,
'cause fairies and magic is all my thing.
I don't know why I missed it.
But your show, watching it,
made me want to watch them.
So now my kids, we're all
watching them at home now.
Because of this series.
It's so cool.
Did you, I don't know,
did you have any pressure?
Like, feeling to,
'cause Lord of the Rings
is such a huge novel.
It's a huge show, it's
just a huge following.
Did y'all feel any pressure?
- Pressure's how you make a diamond, man.
- [Kelly] Yeah, all right.
I like that answer.
- Like, nobody puts as much
pressure on us as ourselves.
We want it to be as good
as we know it can be
and show Tolkien respect,
and they always ask,
"Do you feel pressure from the fans?"
But, we're fans, and we're
taking good care of it.
- Well, and it's interesting
how you're doing it.
Like it's a different time.
And so that's the interesting concept.
So, even if, I was telling
the audience before
the show started, I was like,
even if you haven't seen the
movies, you're gonna love it.
It's such a whole new
world for people that,
like I said, I didn't see the movies.
I'm highly invested in the characters.
I'm very excited about yours.
- (laughs) Thank you.
- I have to start with
asking you to explain those,
this, to the world, though.
For people like me who lived under a rock,
and didn't know Lord the Rings.
Like, what is the show?
What is it about?
- It's obviously a fantasy show,
about Middle Earth.
And our show takes
place thousands of years
before the films,
so you really don't need to know anything.
- [Kelly] I know, yeah.
- It's the first chapter.
It's exactly where
you're supposed to start.
Like, it's the quintessential
battle between good and evil,
light and dark.
- Hope and despair.
- Yeah, hope and despair.
- Misery.
- Misery. Tragedy.
- And of course, we're
all from different races
that are in Middle Earth.
- Yeah.
- Coming together, because
the minute we celebrate that,
the minute we can always erase evil.
- [Kelly] I love that thread, yeah.
(audience clapping)
It's such a beautiful thing.
That's what I loved when I-
and did you love like,
playing your character?
You felt personally kinda connected
to being able to do this, right?
- I felt hugely connected.
I felt hugely connected
because the breakdown
of the character in the
audition, is she's maternal,
and she brings some joy, and you know-
- [Kelly] And you sing.
- [Sophia] And I sing.
- Yeah, you do.
- And,
yeah, so, for me, it just felt
like a really iconic moment.
She is the first female dwarf
to have ever truly been seen
within the world of
Tolkien, or this franchise.
She is the first dwarf of
color to have ever been seen
within this franchise.
(audience clapping)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Thank you.
And so, it felt like a moment to rise.
And I was very, very pregnant
at the time of auditioning.
And so yeah, it was this
it's been a whole lot.
- Oh my God, I hated
working when I was pregnant.
Were-
- Two days away from giving
birth before I auditioned.
- What?
- Maybe engaged, midwives on stage.
- Your diaphragm has left.
- I doing the camera test like this.
- Yeah.
(Sophia laughs)
- Wait, what about costumes?
Was that an issue?
- Costumes. Can I just say,
the first conversation I
had with the design team.
She said, "You're breastfeeding, right?
What do you need?"
- First of all, I love
that someone just said,
"So, you're breastfeeding."
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- But that's so helpful.
'Cause people don't think about that.
- So, there's pictures of my costume
but there's like these
stitchings on the shoulders
and that was literally, in
between takes, me going-
"So what is it, what are we say next?"
(everybody laughing)
- I love that that's kind of
your character in the film too, though.
- Yeah.
- Like very nurturing, and funny,
and it just, it's a
really great character.
- I appreciate it, I do.
- [Kelly] I love y'all's
relationship, it's so cool.
And you play, Markella, you
play, it's a Hobbit, right?
But y'all say, do you say half-foot?
- A Harfoot.
- A Harfoot, yes.
- I was like, but, it's
the Hobbit thing, right?
That's what it is, right?
- Yeah, so they're like, yeah, they are.
So, they're like the
ancestors to the Hobbits.
- [Kelly] Okay.
So they're kind of, you know,
they have the same feet.
They have the same ears.
The feet come up to like,
just above the knee.
They're huge flippers.
And you slip all around all the time.
And then you-
- [Kelly] That's helpful.
- Yeah, it's great, it's really
great at 3AM in the morning.
It's amazing, it's so fun.
And then they,
but the difference is
in their circumstance.
So the Hobbits have the
Shire, and they have the home,
and the Harfoots are
still trying to find that.
- That scene where it all comes to life.
Like, when we first introduced y'all.
I love it.
- I know, it's so cool.
- Yeah, I was like, wait, what?
It was so cool.
Everything came to life.
And I love your character
'cause you're so curious.
And you keep talking about going beyond,
like, where you're from,
and it's, there's just a lot
of great themes, you know,
that are applicable to
society today, as well.
While you're watching
this fantastical thing.
So, I love your character.
It's so fun.
Especially, ah, I don't wanna ruin it.
But when you find something
and I was like, wait, what?
(all laughing)
- [Markella] I was like that as well.
- I know. I was like, what just shot-?
And I was like, what?
And it's really well done.
And you play the High King.
- King of the Elves, ma'am.
- Yes, did you already feel
like you were the role?
- (laughing) No, no. No no.
They put me in like, a gold corset
and I was like, oh, I guess
I'm standing up straight.
- [Kelly] Just another Tuesday.
- [Benjamin] (laughing) Yeah, yeah.
- I love it, though.
And then all the secrecy of the characters
and what's going on.
I love, you need to watch this show.
It's so addictive.
I was so glad
that I had only had two
episodes in it for this,
'cause I was like, I
would've stayed up all night.
(audience clapping)
Now joining us,
from the Lord of the
Rings, the Rings of Power,
say hello to Nazanin Boniadi, Lloyd Owen,
and Ismael Cruz Cordova.
(audience cheers)
(upbeat funky music)
- [Sophia] Look at us!
- I'm so, y'all, this is about to blow up.
I'm just glad I'm talking
to you first, right now.
'Cause I'm like, this show is so good.
So, Time Magazine called
this show TV's biggest bet.
This is, and you're gonna win.
This is such a big franchise
with so much riding on it.
So, Nazanin, so, you said
that you never thought
that you would get this
part as the village healer.
Which I love.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I mean, I was pre-med.
- Why you think you wouldn't
have gotten it though?
- Yeah, I was pre-med and I, you know,
she resonates with me
because she's a healer
and I was gonna be a doctor.
But then, you know,
I started acting in a post-9/11 climate.
So, the roles that were offered to me,
were available to me, weren't this.
Like it's a fantasy, guys.
And I never imagined in a million years
that I would be here, and it just,
fantasy to me is a way for
us to explore humanity.
And it belongs to all of
us, and it's timeless,
and I'm just so proud that
we're all a part of it.
(audience clapping)
- Absolutely.
I'm so glad, you do such a great job.
I love it.
And I'm not gonna ruin
anything for anybody,
but, I'm rooting for something.
(all laughing)
Anyway.
But, tell us about your character.
So, you're a healer, right?
- I'm a healer.
I'm a single mother to
rebellious teenage son.
- [Kelly] I know, right?
- In a forbidden romance
with a handsome elf.
- [Kelly] Okay. See, I didn't
know if I could say it.
- No, you can. You can, you can.
- [Kelly] I was like, hey.
- Common knowledge.
- I like, okay, I didn't know.
And I was like, so there's
something that's really awesome.
I was like, yeah.
I like it, it's forbidden.
- Elves and humans don't-
- [Kelly] I know.
- You're third wheeling, Lloyd.
- Yeah, I am.
(all laughing)
- [Kelly] You're in the
way, Lloyd. (chuckles)
I love your character,
but tell us about yours.
Tell everybody about yours.
- Well, I play Arondir, whose
a Silvan Elf that is tasked
with watching over the
people of the Southlands,
who have sided with the
wrong side of everything,
after siding with
Morgoth, centuries before.
He is a very curious guy.
I say he's a warrior led by his heart.
As you said, he has this
curiosity of the other,
that leads him to explore
further to have this conflict,
and to actually find the
magic in the unknown.
And those things that we're told
that we're not supposed to be with,
Or, we're taught to reject.
So, that's how he finds this one.
You're third wheeling again, man.
- Get out of the way, Lloyd.
No, what's your, what's your character?
Tell everybody what your character is.
- So, I play a character called Elendil,
and if you know the Lord of the Rings,
he's Aragon's 38th
great, great grandfather.
So, Viggo Mortensen's my grandson.
So, that's nice.
- [Ismael] 38th?
- [Kelly] So, that's nice.
- Yes, so that's nice.
(all laugh)
- Where he starts at the
beginning of the series,
he's a sea captain, very capable.
But he's recently been widowed.
So he is trying to bring up
these three adult children.
And the turbulence that's
happened in the family
because of that grief, is huge.
And he's also getting
sucked into the politics
of this beautiful island of Numenor,
which is Tolkien's Atlantis.
It's like a paradise on earth.
But it's right at the precipice
of the beginnings of
a potential civil war.
And he is getting sucked into that.
So, he's a beautiful character to play.
It's a real battle between
his head and his heart.
And ultimately, he may
well get to be a king
but it's gonna be a long
journey before that happens.
Reluctant hero.
- I love, what a great tease,
for everything, that was really well-
(audience clapping)
I was like, if anybody didn't wanna watch,
they're watching now.
That was well done, Lloyd.